Over 30 years since Return of the Jedi, Harrison
Ford, Carrie Fisher, and Mark Hamill are back
with a new young cast to take us to a galaxy
far, far away.
I'm Jan and this is 15 things you probably
didn't know about Star Wars: The Force Awakens.
The design of Kylo Ren's lightsaber was partly
inspired by a dinner party conversation between
director JJ Abrams and his friend Jonathan
Ive, who just happens to be Apple's Chief
Design Officer.
Ive suggested the new lightsaber should be
less precise, more uneven or "spitty", as
he put it, and added that making it more "more
analogue and more primitive" would give it
a "more ominous" feel.
Captain Phasma's shiny armoured costume was
actually originally pitched as a costume for
Kylo Ren.
For story reasons, JJ Abrams decided it wouldn't
work for that character, but liked the design
so much that he decided it was perfect for
Captain Phasma.
In fact, that silvery chrome-like design reminded
Abrams of a 1979 horror film in which the
antagonist attacks his victims with a silver
sphere.
The name of that film was Phantasm, which
provided the inspiration for the name of Captain
Phasma.
Oh, and by the way, according to screenwriter
Lawrence Kasdan, Captain Phasma was originally
going to be a male character but the role's
gender was later swapped and Gwendoline Christie
was cast.
The hard, white plasticky look of Stormtroopers
made costume designer Michael Kaplan think
of his iPhone, which gave him the idea for
the sleek look of the Stormtrooper costumes
in The Force Awakens.
The new Stormtrooper costumes are also tougher
and more flexible than the original vacuum-formed
suits as they were cast in a thicker polyurethane
plastic.
Oscar Isaac's character Poe Dameron was partly
named after JJ Abrams' assistant at Bad Robot,
Morgan Dameron.
However, Abrams can't quite remember the origins
of the character's first name, but thinks
it may have been subconsciously named after
his daughter's toy polar bear which is called
Po.
As for the name BB-8, according to Abrams
both the letter B and the number 8 were just
"sort of how [the droid] looked to [him]"
and he simply liked the onomatopoeic sound
of the name.
Before going on set, to ready herself to play
Rey, Daisy Ridley would listen in her trailer
to I'll Make A Man Out Of You from Disney's
1998 animated feature Mulan.
And that wasn't Ridley's only musical experience
while filming The Force Awakens.
The young actress, who specialised in musical
theatre at Tring Park School for the Performing
Arts in the UK, says she couldn't stop singing
on set to the point that director JJ Abrams
actually bet her she couldn't make it a whole
day without bursting into song!
When he auditioned for the role of Finn in
The Force Awakens, John Boyega watched Mark
Hamill and Harrison Ford's original Star Wars
auditions on YouTube and drew inspiration
from approach to the material.
Boyega's favourite character in all the Star
Wars movies is Han Solo because he relates
to Solo's attitude of 'just trying to make
some money and get by'.
Carrie Fisher was not only told to lose weight
to play Princess Leia in the very first Star
Wars movie, despite only weighing 105 pounds
at the time, but Fisher says she also had
to lose over 35 pounds for The Force Awakens.
Mark Hamill also shed around 50 pounds to
return to the world of Star Wars.
JJ Abrams brought Oscar-winning special effects
artist and animatronics wiz Neal Scanlan out
of retirement to bring to life the creatures
of The Force Awakens.
Scanlan's team designed over 100 creatures,
using a mix of prosthetics and animatronics,
while some even had 5 or 6 people inside operating
them.
The emphasis was on recreating the practical
feel of the creatures from the original trilogy,
while making the best use of technological
advances like 3-D printing and small elements
of CGI to enhance the final look.
As R2-D2 is such a fan favourite, it seems
fitting that The Force Awakens version of
everyone's favourite blue-and-white droid
was actually built by two Star Wars uber-fans!
At the 2013 Star Wars Celebration in Germany,
Kathleen Kennedy was so impressed by the fully-functioning
R2-D2 replica made by Lee Towersey and Oliver
Steeples, who are British members of the R2
Builders Club, that she recommended them to
work on the movie!
The new R2-D2 the pair built for the film
is made of fibreglass and aluminium.
So, you may know that the Millennium Falcon's
circular sensor dish was replaced with a rectangular
one for The Force Awakens as the original
was lost when Lando flew the ship in Return
of the Jedi.
But the production designers also accommodated
a special request from Harrison Ford that
the dashboard switches on the new Falcon have
proper springs so they'd stay in place when
they were flipped.
As a keen amateur pilot Ford was irritated
that the original Falcon's switches didn't
do that.
Composer John Williams, who scored the original
Star Wars trilogy and the prequels, has likened
writing music for The Force Awakens to "adding
paragraphs to a letter that's been going on
for a number of years."
However, Williams didn't consult his scores
for the previous films before starting work
on his seventh Star Wars movie because, he
says, "it's a bit like riding a bike that
you haven't been on since you were ten years
old.
You do remember."
After director JJ Abrams bumped into composer
Lin-Manuel Miranda at a performance of Miranda's
hugely successful Broadway musical Hamilton,
Abrams asked him to compose music for a Cantina-style
scene in The Force Awakens.
However, Miranda didn't actually get to see
the scene he was scoring.
Abrams just sent him the temporary music they'd
been using and Miranda took it from there,
exchanging music files with Abrams over email
until the pair had completed the co-written
piece.
Although a huge fan of the original Star Wars
trilogy, JJ Abrams very nearly turned down
the opportunity to direct The Force Awakens
as, when producer Kathleen Kennedy first approached
him, he was still busy on post-production
for Star Trek Into Darkness and didn’t want
to take on another huge franchise especially
as he had plans for a 6-month family vacation.
But when Kennedy told him he’d have a blank
canvas for the film, Abrams felt the chance
to explore what had happened to Han, Leia
and Luke since we last saw them was just too
big to pass up.
Now, who are your favourite characters in
Star Wars: The Force Awakens & why?
And which is your favourite Star Wars movie?
Let me know in the comments below!
I've got more Star Wars videos on the way
including a movie review and an easter egg
video, and I'll add the annotations here when
they're live.
If you'd liked to see more videos like this,
do please subscribe, like and share!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!